et
c'est le président américain qui fait
crisser les pneus de cette voiture
électrique pour prouver qu'elles sont
aussi efficaces que les voitures à
essence
ont tourné au michigan pour vendre son
plan sur l'infrastructure joe biden
martèle le même message buy american
achetez américain
nous créons des incitatifs des crédits
d'impôts dit il pour les américains qui
achètent des véhicules électriques
assemblée aux états unis
on veut s'assurer que les emplois
restent hills au michigan dit il
mais tout ceci crée un terrible
précédent des cuisses fesses en expert
sur les relations entre les deux pays
jobin est issu d'une famille de cols
bleus dit il il a toujours été proche
des syndicats est plutôt sceptique par
rapport au libre échange qui brise
pas il est persuadé que dans notre champ
pas voler le vote des travailleurs du
parti démocrate dit il et il veut les
récupérer bin hammam
achetez américain répétait joba donne
trois mois après son élection devant un
congrès presque vide à cause de la
pandémie mais conquis une devise qui
respecte toujours à la lettre et qui
n'est finalement pas si différente que
le mérite que first l'amérique d'abord
dans notre chambre
à peine élu il a même créé un poste de
directeur de médine america à la maison
blanche il signe alors un décret
présidentiel qui stipule que l'avenir
est made in america buy american ce fait
aux états unis par des américains il a
beau dire qu'il veut renforcer son
partenariat avec le canada et le mexique
sur différents dossiers comme le climat
et l'immigration sa politique demeure
protectionnistes au grand dam du canada
selon cette professeur d'économie les
etats unis doivent au contraire
renforcer leur partenariat économique
avec le canada pour moins dépendre de la
chine comme crit a
si on veut concurrencer avec l'asie dit
elle au lieu d'être à leur solde il faut
repenser le développement de l'économie
nord-américaine et l'intégrer la rupture
des chaînes d'approvisionnement à cause
de la pandémie a une fois de plus révélé
une grande dépendance envers la chine
le canada comme levier les matières
premières dites l énergie mais aussi le
secteur manufacturier
mais à moins d'un an des élections de
mi-mandat la priorité de joe biden est
de regagner le vote des syndicats et des
travailleurs et le protectionnisme est
plutôt populaire chez ces électeurs là
il ya des bordelais guerguisse
radio-canada projecteurs